welcome to this video Omega P Omega P no
played this guy ok I just played g6
maybe a modern maybe a king's indian
let's see ok doing something the
different yeah trying to attack his
default on quickly ok kicking as a very
wow he really doesn't want to keep the
porn right so I'm going to take it it's
quite funny i don't really threaten this
because 24 at the end but anyway the
rukon b8 is probably not that bad ok
yeah the night yes kind of funny one
bump slight problems if i go d 6 is got
94 and c6 is really weak so I'm trying
this trying to hand pies development a
little bit not so clear how he is going
to develop now bishop therefore i can
take be 2 or any other bishop move for
that matter it's not so clear make it
got some activity I mean d4 takes on c5
c6 costs quite some time
yeah what is he going to do now or
question what I'm going to do but it's
bit annoying
maybe I can play d5 next move just d5
then on 94 this Bishop d7 this kind of
maybe you just plays it anyway okay we
should be be 74 c 5 maybe c5 immediately
is also possible let's do that night b3
i have queen before I didn't really
expect that move but maybe you should be
seven I thought I Scotty for maybe yeah
okay let's play he does not really um
here my horse can play this or
okay it's not bad anyway he's not really
threatening to take on a seven I think
okay and let's take them and 95 s as
idea okay drop back for night c 7 or
possibly queen b 7 i'm going to do that
or maybe hmm i wonder if I good if I
give the check first ok I don't know
it's probably useless to spend much time
here ok and now i have d 5 and this is a
chance i want to take gaining space in
the center maybe for deform let's do
that this runs into this runs into
Bishop c7 so let's do that 95 s maybe a
move that is in the position funny move
95
it's definitely playable a 6 but e6 is
also good yeah what kind of squares that
it's not really great it's pushing 5 you
four come on yeah hmm intermediate
tricks probably not not helping I wonder
if before is a move this kind of this
kind of thing trying to undermine no
it's not doing that so III or is there a
breakthrough let's prevent before I mean
it does not look like he wants to play
it but still it's prevented yeah that's
that's not an issue the night coming to
to to be five is not not a problem the
night is not doing anything there it's
basically just just looking good check
the other Kuniko one light looks nice
but never wins nycha form mm-hmm is
there anything better you g5 is also
quite quite nice
a g5 is suspect am I'm threatening
g-form and it's really his hard pressed
to make a move the night is basically
like a piece down it's just off site and
those pawns d43 divided the board into
I mean probably not the only movement
yeah me I was actually added an
hallucination yeah i was thinking i have
root page eight but the rook was still
on the seventh it's really not mattering
much he has no no kind of no defense
because of this configuration is just so
terrible night XD falls probably the
best chance relatively speaking didn't
do that can also just take doe cam check
look at for Queen edge one mate it's
just a big problem one of them
yeah that's still still in the game in
the in the mix yeah comes back let's
just finish this off him check check
yeah that meant what I said went
downhill surprisingly quickly went the
route around here when he is really not
good a thing to allow d5 this just gives
black here when he when he when he he
have three f3 is a isn't isn't any good
I think he has to do something else
maybe just take on c7 something it's
something like that can never be
anything great for for either side so
not equal i guess i mean i don't mind to
be black here and then I rather am black
then white in this position because I
have an idea at least but it is it is
equal but this is this is really a
problem here I am I mean pawn takes d5
is also not good and here well I'm just
I'm just gaining space in the sand down
here here and I here after that it gets
really problematic I the computer is an
interesting line this is also good this
is a typical computer projet are very
direct very strong it detects this and
threaten screens you three white has
actually white has no move here that I
mean I'm probably winning the whole
queenside very strong okay well I was
more looking for some of them so I
really think he has to go before in some
some way I don't don't really think it
works but Queenie 6 computer move which
is kinda weird it seems to win don't
really understand why
check we need to okay Queenie to is
indeed strong yes yeah that's indeed
strong still gap you want hangs okay
well can't hear after a five I think
it's almost lost what is the comp giving
minus one point for now probably
climbing yeah just an attack no 44
absolutely i mean and i don't have any
am NOT material down and well this is
this is helping of course here chief is
somewhat tougher it's still very good
for for black but it's not clear that
I'm that I'm winning so easily what's so
easy to open up lines chassis I get them
just have the H farm yeah yeah like De
Quincey em yeah this is a very very
interesting point sometimes nights on be
five or before they quite often look
good but what exactly are they doing in
this case this night is just standing
around as a spectator doesn't do
anything and this is quite often the
case in in various openings if you maybe
if you remember in the recent Tata Steel
tournament there was a game live on
uronian with white against Barack Obama
as your Baba put his night wire a 62
before in a benoni and the night was
just completely out of the out of the
plain white had had a big attack and the
night couldn't help so very often those
nights are looking nice but they don't
do anything yeah well thanks for
watching